[Music]
welcome everybody
we are half yes
we are half a mile underground in an
undisclosed location in our 20 billion
dollars hell yeah brother uh shelter
that's right fallout shelter and uh we
have a great show here for you guys for
a change
yeah
we are all domestic terrorists normally
our
normally our show sucks but today for a
change we're gonna have again when we
decided not today yeah so uh welcome
nice to see you Hassan uh have you seen
my new Teddy fresh shirt this one's
inspired by by my uh clever this is my
clever design Zuck is a soul-second
demon yes I like that
King out a little bit on the meat shop
but you can wear it he's in front of
like a Data Center and it's all on fire
people are perishing and deeper I'll
turn on some key technology really quick
yeah hold on there you go whoa oh whoa I
can't believe you just like wheeled in a
green screen that quickly behind Ethan
all right and ready three two one
and a shot damn that's perfect wow
yeah so that's available teddyfresh.com
thank you thank you how you doing Hassan
I'm doing I'm doing all right I'm a
little I'm feeling a little stagnant in
general but I'm doing all right
you're not getting gains is that why no
no no no I'm not front I'm fine I've
been I've been looking good you know I'm
feeling good ready to take your shirt
off no not yet yeah I mean I can I can
you know I just like let me see them
titties a little bit you know
okay
you wanna see the nipple I kind of
because that's not enough okay well
that's pretty big
our medium size a healthy size nipple I
would say I I have normal nipples I used
to be really insecure about my nipples
that's why I always take photos
no when I was really fat and I had like
a like a hormone issue I guess when I
was growing up my nipples were like
indented they went they went inside yeah
like they looked like uh puffy eyes you
know like how uh like Ian's eyes after
the fight like that's right okay
interesting so now since you've lost the
weight that the nipples are looking good
they're looking normal and yes so I show
them off you know good for you I bet
he's got some big old giant [__] tits
that's that's not true Alex
that's not fair yeah Alex you better you
better stop that now yeah actually
there's a lot of great stories that
we've got queued up today uh some of my
favorite kind of conservative stories
coming along for example uh Elon Musk
offered a bounty for anyone that could
prove that his dad owned an emerald mind
and somebody stepped forward to uh claim
that uh reward his dad yeah
his dad provided all the receipts and
said nah I owned an emerald mine and I
gave him a bunch of money to move to
America to be honest that's Sigma grind
said
that is Sigma grind set like you're
you're you know you're taking advantage
of any opportunity you got if your son's
like the one of the wealthiest
billionaires on the planet at least just
own it I don't know why he gotta act
like he like swam here from South Africa
or some [__] he was also a Visa over
stair he was an undocumented immigrant
for a long time
oh he's a v he oh he's overstayed yeah
his Visa was like slated to expire
because like his his
um College
his his like College admission was in a
state of disarray um and then he just
kind of stayed and then was able to get
into another University to you know well
there it is according to Elon Musk if
your Visa expires just stay and figure
it out
I got an issue with that at all I think
that's you know I'm I'm very much
supportive of that well it's just not
it's just not the advice that I got when
ELO was here in her V6 where we had to
get the [__] out and go to Israel yeah
Yeah well yeah but we were you're not
yeah well you're not [__] your your
daddy don't own no Emerald mine so
that's kind of how that works so my dad
sold bikes yeah the Far Cry from uh
Emerald yeah but it suck another one
Matt Walsh got hacked all kinds of good
things came out of that Fox News settled
with Dominion for 787 million dollars
[__] loser ass idiots yeah that was
kind of [__] up and my favorite story
of the week is that um
Alexander Ali Alexander one of the stars
of the alt-right stop the seal this guy
is a [__]
freakazoid
and a shocking unprecedented
unforeseeable twist he's been outed as a
Boomer pedophile and also gay a gay what
are you doing he's asking for dick pics
from underage boys
what it's almost it's almost like the
groomers and the pedophiles are all
conservatives you hate to see one of
your favorite one of your favorites
behave like this you know what I mean
not you Ali it's such a this is a
troubling time for me in particular I
was a fan of uh the Habsburg jaw demon
yeah personally he's my favorite of the
Habsburg family here he is did you know
that he looks uh I don't know if we did
see the Sammy Davis Jr connection
I can see that
um do you do you want to pull up a
hashberg jaw real quick
hold on you got to see this uh and by
the way he's friends with Nick Fuentes
who uh is now actually the Close
Associates with Nick Fuentes the guy
who's like besties with Kanye teaching
him to be a lot of a lot of cool guys
well the interesting part is that Nick
is now being uh under deep scrutiny from
his own fans because as it turns out
Nick knew about this uh for a long time
in fact yeah I did nothing let's just
save this for when we cover the story
because I got so many
funny opinions about that and it's just
the story is so funny I mean we could
get into it now if we're on it but Milo
yiannopoulos the uh provocateur and born
again don't tell me he also no he's the
one that exposed the sword don't tell me
he also may or may not have like
defended pedophilia oh I hate yeah I
hate to break it I'm so sorry what the
[__] man answer my face I know on Joe
Rogan he said that uh he says that these
look these kind of pedophilic grooming
relationships are really transformative
and healthy he said for young gay men so
that's kind of what he said about that
oh my what the [__] so this is uh this
is a a that looks like British royalty
my friend so Spanish technically but but
they're all actually British royalties
banners royalty Australian royalty it
doesn't really matter it's basically all
the same because of centuries of
systemic inbreeding this is a
genetically traceable uh uh you know
disability
that uh you see in the Habsburg family
it's kind of interesting like you can
literally tell which lineage certain uh
Royals come from by looking at like what
kind of how [__] up their faces are
I wish I was joking I'm not joking this
is real so this guy is a heritable trait
this dude has this [__] up jaw
that he just passed on to every to like
no no it's not this dude it's because
here's what happens when you're like
constantly marrying sisters and cousins
like
ultimately in in like a normal situation
let's say you marry like a second cousin
right
um the the uh
the likelihood of you passing down some
kind of like uh genetic disability to
your next of kin is still higher than if
you didn't do that but it's still
significantly lower than the royal
family doing it on the right because the
royal family the royal family is so
inbred right for so many years that like
a second cousin marrying one another and
having sex with one another is like the
same as like two brothers right like a
brother and a sister right that makes
sense brother and sister want to make
love even closer than that in some
instances is really there's nothing
wrong with that I mean brother and
sister making love I mean well Dennis
Frazier doesn't think so and he's oh God
I really hope that he hasn't like
written an article about how spousal
rape is fine or something you know oh
Dennis no mommy has written that stop no
I know all my faves dude he did write
that article
there isn't any for Dennis Prager I I
really love his work on on you know
incestuous relationships that was why I
liked him a lot he's done he's done
amazing work in terms of normalizing
incest uh he's fantastic on that he
actually teaches a class on on a and how
to
enable and uh make make incest uh happy
and good times you want to make love
let's see what we got some good stuff at
the top of the show and then we'll get
into all this fun conservative stuff but
um
4 20 first of all blaze it
we put I don't wanna I was trying not to
tell you what have you been drinking we
put like a full tincture vial in that
[__] thing hell yeah dude
hell yeah
I'm so suited right now ass brought up
okay you're at Creator Clash you had a
good time you were supporting our boy
thank you for that you were there for
myth also uh a family of sorts through a
b yeah family in the sense that you
yelled at him one time yeah I took it
yeah well duh who do you yell at more
than your own family that's true you
know what I mean Andrew yeah I I went
down I went down to Tampa to to link up
with uh Charlie and to also obviously
support uh Ali and everybody else and
Ali Alexander yeah Ollie Alexander he
was there I thought that's what you're
saying yeah
no I
but all right well none of that it was a
wonderful experience it was great none
of that [__] matters what matters is
that you are hanging out with this dumb
[__] a-rack this traitor to the family
and not only were you hanging out with
arack that's not bad enough you're
hanging out with this goofy dumb sellout
[__] dude I'm not gonna lie he kind of
he kind of won me over a little bit he
seems like a really nice dude yeah like
all psychopaths are like Charming yeah
he put the charm on me yeah just wait
till you he needs something for ass like
me you think like what happened he's
doing psychotic like charm [__] dude he
is so he is so cunning and charismatic I
think that's fine what did he say that
was so charismatic he was just such a
nice guy he came in uh he came first of
all he clearly puts a lot of time and
effort in the gym I mean look how
gigantic his shoulders are so we vibed
on that immediately we were like oh yeah
look like you have massive shoulders I
have massive shoulders disgusting I beat
his ass I beat his ass
um he did say he beat your ass well it's
on video that's not what happened he he
said he's Oliver won that fight well I
won the other one pretty thoroughly I
got him good I got him good he actually
made you have a seizure if you recall oh
right yeah I forgot about the ending oh
no so you were doing well the whole
fight but in the ending I got him I
clocked him good I won the other turn uh
also Jonas is a [__] traitor ass
[__] too he could win against the
family you know when David dobrik
dropped Jeff I have no idea who that
males he [__] bailed on his boy Jeff
they had a show together and he's like
no I gotta stay with Daddy dobrik you
[__] [__] absolutely zero clue who
that guy is uh his name is Jonah but
he's well you know I mean he was kind of
funny
exactly so let's see what other enemies
of the people are here
um Bryce is cool
yeah his name is actually Nick
they call him Jonah because they say it
looks like Jonah Hill oh that's all I've
heard them say yeah didn't even get his
fake name right you were like Jonas
whatever everybody knew what I was
talking about
uh and King Bach who is uh of course
on top uh Bach I don't know
back yeah
King Beethoven is it b-a-c-h no I I
[__] that up too sometimes what did
you spell it back bch this guy hasn't
made a [__] video and uh that anybody
watched in 10 years how am I supposed to
they're doing Snapchat stuff apparently
like a lot yeah I don't know why he's
got to catch Strays he's fine actually I
think he's working with Ryan Kavanaugh I
heard I don't know if it's really yeah
oh no dude Ryan Cavanaugh was there too
we were just hanging out Brian Cavanaugh
was jerking off in the corner I bet yeah
we were we were just all hanging out
we're like man
we're all best buds huh why did they
invite you to this I I don't know uh
Eric asked me okay he DM me and he was
like yo can you like you're the Riz Lord
like can you come and like [__] my robot
and I was like dude I'm there
I I love that what was the video I mean
what the video was like uh it was
basically a competition I'm not gonna
leak who won
um but it was basically a competition to
to rise up this robot uh Sophie who had
is like basically like a chat gbt
connected to like uh you know this this
Android thing
um she can also react to visual stimuli
though that's like kind of unique I
guess she has like a chess camera as you
can see why does Eric have this [__]
freak
um he rented her out okay women that
sounds like sex trafficking uh for this
video all right I don't like him here's
why I don't like wait why first of all
waiting back or whatever is not even in
this let's let's address it piece by
piece let's go one by one you don't like
Eric why all right you want to know why
I don't like Aaron your podcast and then
you like them yeah that's what you know
exactly you want to know why I hate Eric
because then year of the Streamys that I
was robbed of a [__] win because of
but leftovers is a part of the atriation
Productions podcast franchise that's
true so I was technically robbed right
right beside you okay that's fair well
what happened mad at me by proxy well
yeah dude because you're what you know
if like
listen
you know if I'm a Jew in New York during
World War II and I find out my homie's
been over in Germany then I'm going to
be a little annoyed you know what I mean
here is uh what Eric had to say about me
who wasn't even in attendance who got
burned
check it out but Ethan Klein takes his
off next wait let me go back just for a
low cost
a huge year he finally took off the mask
let's go dream dream to buff the mask
let's hope Ethan Klein takes his off
next
huh oh I'm being told this is actual
this is actual face yo that was straight
up they piped that laughter in what the
[__]
you think yeah nobody laughed in there
in the room I promise listen
they probably cut the notice how the
video the audio cuts out and it turns
into Applause it's actually they're
booing him that's what I would expect
yeah yeah like that okay uh I'm so
stoked yeah so this guy goes oh
socialism with a big house by the way
you know he did that yeah [__] him yeah
I mean I don't give a [__]
he's L not funny oh so I'm just the
ugliest dude on YouTube that everyone's
like oh yeah Ethan's ugly he goes oh
yeah next I heard Ethan's gonna take off
his mask oh wait that's his real face oh
everybody's on the same page Ethan's the
ugliest [__] no one thought that
that's what the joke means everyone
everyone thought you were hot at the at
the crow I asked them afterwards right I
asked every single person that uh about
this I gave an ocular pat down to every
single person in the vicinity and I was
like do you think Ethan is hot would you
[__] Ethan Klein and they were like yeah
definitely Unfortunately they were
talking about the fake Ethan that we
sent he is he is good looking he's very
good looking yeah you're better looking
than him King no he's he's handsome
don't get me don't listen what did I
tell you all of these other people they
are wifeless okay they are childless
so you automatically you you won on that
front so you could just be like L ratio
I got kids you don't sucks to suck yeah
dude and two of Kavanaugh's uh but then
they can counter try to say in here two
of Kevin's Protege but then you had
counter you had an opportunity my friend
dude to strike a huge dub for that you
want me to do we killed them
that would have taken out half of
Kavanaugh's roster dude yeah I mean I
want them to make money I don't give a
[__] where they're getting it from you
know what I mean it's easy for you to
say you're not being sued by by four
times by him
yeah don't worry I mean it's not like
those projects are gonna make a lot of
money yeah so anyway whatever so if
anything it's good that they're working
with them anyway listen I'm just kidding
they're milking them dry it's all good
and uh well this was a picture that uh
well there it is
yeah but uh you you chatted with Oliver
he's a he's a good guy he's okay wow
whoa whoa whoa breaking the illusion is
this the fear sitting inside of you now
that he I'm pretty sure he's gonna
challenge you to a fight again
he can come here any [__] time
there's an open door is that is that why
you're fearful it seems like you're a
little fearful why you're just saying
nice things about him now to like
I don't know I'm just trying to break
the ice I'm just trying to like I I'm
just trying to make it less awkward in
here I mean yeah I [__] hate him he's
a piece of [__]
probably a groomer too ah okay that was
too far just kidding yeah he's there's
no evidence to support that all right
let's move on
um yeah that's a betrayal uh speaking of
betrayals so we can talk about the I
guess Elon musk's dad I mean this story
is awesome
here's his dad who looks a lot like him
that's the real family betrayal right
there
not what I did let's see in January Elon
tweeted out
the fake Emerald thing is so annoying
sigh what a what a teenager yeah Psy no
it's not even a teenager you know what
it is you know what it is it's like
it's like was it Chive
what was that website
like the image board or whatever like
it's like nine gag but even older oh wow
I think it was it was like it's like
it's a bygone era it's the type of like
this is like an older Millennial trait
to just like type like this epic narwhal
bacon at midnight like that kind of [__]
that's what he's doing his entire
posting career is like being perma-stuck
in 2011 you know what I mean he just
talks like he's that's why he loves uh
Rick and Morty and [__] well you know he
said where exactly is this thing anyway
and actually the funniest thing is that
they they at the users they eat at the
concepts they said listen
uh in a 2004 phone interview with ask
men must said this is going to sound
crazy but my father had a share in an
Elber mind in Zambia
Emerald mine and Zambia so whoa that's
crazy wait you got context checked on
his own platform yeah he was just he was
they wanted to link to it he was talking
about it on Tucker Carlson like uh I
really like uh the context check uh
journalist fear it it's like bro [__]
you should fear it yeah more than anyone
else I'm actually surprised he left that
up because he doesn't seem to have much
of a problem with erasing criticism but
here is the the uh
here's the interview
you know so that's kind of a l for him
but then he goes on just to put out a
challenge he challenges the people of
the internet he says
I I will pay a million
Dogecoin for proof of this mind's
existence
um what is that a million Dogecoin what
does that mean how much money like a
hundred how much money is that in real
money that you can buy things with 100
000 hundred thousand okay so a hundred
thousand back when he said that maybe
you know ninety thousand now who knows
let's see uh uh one million Doge to USD
it's uh 83 700 wow that's lost a bit of
uh value there huh yeah God I [__]
well his dad heated the call he's like I
can prove it uh listen
uh he has previously he said he's elon's
been slamming uh critics saying the fake
Emerald mine thing is so annoying like
where did this come from but an
exclusive
with the U.S Sun Errol claimed it was
his Emerald Venture which helped pave
the way for Elon to become a wildly
successful Captain of industry
describing the moment he heard of
Dogecoin cryptocurrency award he joked
when I read that I wondered can I enter
Because I can prove it exists
Elon knows it's true all the kids knew
about it my daughter has three or four
Emerald pendants dude his dad [__]
hates him or something yeah I mean he
does yeah they have beef huh his dad is
like isn't his dad like weird as [__] he
like married his like yeah marrying he
did the old married
I think he might be like a sex criminal
I don't know about that but he did marry
his much younger stepdaughter I believe
dude dude what though it's so odd when
people hearing your stepdaughter is like
immediate jail I I you should not you
should not be accepted from in society
if you marry your stepdaughter yeah uh
he married a stepdaughter who uh by the
way was four years old when Errol
married her mother that is so vile so
[__] obscene sick [__] that you know
what that means it means he was
eyeballing her the whole time oh stop
okay I don't even want to think about
that oh God this is going to be such a
groomer dance uh episode today
a lot of [__] weird sick perverted
reactionaries all around well listen
it's just this is an isolated incident
it's all on the left it's drag queens
it's trans people that are yeah all
groomers trust me yeah
um let's see
uh Elon saw the emeralds at our house he
knew I was selling them to prove his
point Arrow provided picks to some of
the bright green precious grimstones
gemstones which he says came from the
mine he explained that it was in the
Lake
Tanganyika
tanjanika region of Zambia the second
biggest Emerald producing country in the
world after Colombia but Errol admits it
was far from being a conventional mining
setup which might explain why Elon was
so sure nobody could prove its existence
yeah which means it's like extra illegal
you know what I mean which is wild
because like the legal processes is
already like disastrously uh close to
slavery in general so like the fact that
it was also on top of that like even
more illegal uh that's terrifying
explaining why he thinks that Elon keeps
pushing back on them sorry sorry go up
Italian man at the time when zombie was
there you go no one owned anything the
deal was done on a handshake with the
Italian man at the time when Zambia was
a free-for-all there was no Mining
Company there are no sign agreements or
financials I love that an Italian dude
is selling them Zambian land yeah not
even he knew exactly where the Border
was at that time it was like the Wild
West
good time to make some money uh he says
elon's main concern is not to appear to
be a trusted fund kid who got everything
given to him on a plate oh come on how
dare you I got this oh God I can't get
over it because like I'm I'm even I'm
obviously also upset at the fact that
like
these [__] are so openly
discussing how they just like stole
natural resources from uh a a uh
purposely impoverished country like this
you know what I mean like they're
they're just so callous uh in their
disregard for human life and then you
have dumbasses go look at Africa it's so
poor I wonder why it's like yeah [__]
this is the reason actually the most
nefarious one that I see people doing is
like the bell curve where they go no
black people are dumb yeah they're just
Dumber
which is of course totally debunked in
insanely races yeah it's just a a weird
way to try to justify your racist
beliefs through the lens of science I
guess let's see I managed to send uh
them about 115 000 in total it helped
them survive with rent and food
Kimball told me they could never survive
it's and there's nothing wrong with your
parents helping you I mean a lot of
people their parents help them out Elon
don't be a [__] [__]
I'll be a liar ass [__] dude dumbass
loser idiot dumbass
I I at this point like I just you know I
I've I've hated Elon Musk for a very
long time I'm pretty open about that but
like the disdain I have for his dick
riders is unimaginable
like I can't
whenever
he does another idiotic thing
and uh you know and and there's plenty
of it all the time like uh
claiming on April 1st that he was going
to eviscerate blue check marks only to
realize that like verified Legacy check
marks is the only reason why people are
buying check marks to begin with to do
people into thinking that they have
check marks and then finding out that
and then stopping that process
immediately when he found out because
people were making fun of him on Twitter
only to then banned me I mean he has
done so many stupid things no he's
Banning you was good actually that was
the only good thing seriously
um uh yeah he he's just a big dummy
idiot loser and I love to see it oh
speaking of all the checkmark stuff
because you know he said today was the
day they were going to get rid of yeah
marks I just went to Ethan's account and
it literally loaded and the check mark
was there and then it just disappeared
so so he's saying let's take a look he's
removed check marks for see I still see
it on mine it was there and then like as
the page loaded it suddenly disappeared
so it happened to Hassan Stu so wait
he's removing check marks for people not
paying is that what I'm still seeing
supposedly today it's probably gonna be
buggy as [__] you know what's happening
like okay people who have verified check
marks I mean how many can there be how
much money is he hoping to generate
forcing public fig here's the pay for
Twitter blue look at your dumbass loser
it's gone it still shows on on my
um on on the page that I'm looking at on
my desktop and it shows on my mobile
this don't go away I'm sure it's cope
no I believe you I'm sure like
it's totally glitching because Ethan has
a check for me now
have a check for you for yourself
check mark still yeah I see it you know
he would never take it from me I mean
I'm just famous I don't know
God gave you that check well I got bad
news
I got bad news for you but that means
you're gay on my screen that [__] gone
no
this is really gonna stop impersonators
and spam Bots yeah no that's it's great
it may it's like it actually certainly
will make the website better it's
actually so stupid when I have to do
like uh
when I have to do like a five minute uh
precursory search to figure out whether
or not on the drill that I'm looking at
or like if the L is like a one or a
[__] weird ASI uh letter and that's
like if you want to make sure that you
like that's that's when you have media
literacy many people don't even do that
they don't give a [__] they don't care
they're just gonna see anyone and
anything that resembles like a a real
account and go oh that's Hassan [__]
right there he said that actually that's
Eli Lilly what's interesting
is that I can't impersonate him now
because I don't have the blue check mark
right that was the thing
uh correct so now I guess I can just go
buck wild with the Elon impersonation
Twitter is so pointless dude I'm so over
it
it sucks it's uh it's a platform that I
use primarily for news aggregation like
all the journalists usually break their
stories on the platform before they
write and publish it
um it's a really really great way to
stay ahead of the news cycle and
understand what's going on
um it's become increasingly difficult to
do that
with uh you know under the Elon regime
and it's becoming worse and worse every
day my for you pages of men my for you
page is just 100 rage bait yeah and I'm
like I can't be here this is just a
nightmare for me remember when Elon said
he would step down if they he did yeah
yeah that happened he never did that he
lost yeah pretty significantly in that
poll huh it's a big bummer oh God he
lies a lot that's crazy I would have
never thought well anyway let's move on
uh putting Ron Ron DeSantis we've been
wondering before that yeah there's some
breaking news but BuzzFeed news the news
arm of BuzzFeed
uh is being shut down right I almost I
almost felt like they're not it's not
even worthy of an obituary but uh well
no I'm open the article that I linked
and you'll understand what a loss this
is I mean they broke this huge story
that uh kids YouTube Star blippi regrets
the viral video in which he poops all
over his friend have you seen that video
son no I have no idea what the [__] this
is I don't want to watch it no no no
stop you'll have to watch this no dude
oh my God this is important we've all
seen it I need like I need to wash my
eyes you know who blippi is right what
no who the [__] you don't know who
blippi is no dog okay then dude
he's the biggest child Entertainer on
Youtube huge why would I know that then
I don't know he's big everybody
fucking's got like a knee come on
everybody knows blippi
dude he's got those fire songs like uh
I have no idea
here comes the train I have no idea
what's all over his homie pull it up I
will defend Katie though Katie does a
really good work actually like he's
looking for a job
um as far as like uh you know online
Trends uh things like that
uh I I do think that she does a pretty
pretty good job overall uh and BuzzFeed
news was a pretty solid team overall as
well I think most people they were like
breaking stories yes supposed to be news
did solid journalism for this short
duration that they survived and lived
and why did they not change the name I
never understood that the brand BuzzFeed
is so tainted that I feel like it
legitimately because you hear BuzzFeed
news it's like oh that's [__] yeah
phone David made a website for it they
were so proud Harlem shakepoop.com
are you pulling it up Dan it's in
Discord okay so obviously Ian don't show
it so here's blippi the biggest child uh
Entertainer on Youtube uh this was his
first attempt at Fame on YouTube
the Harlem Shake of course was a big
thing
that bathroom is so sad
[Music]
is he
oh oh
no no then look look at that that's
blippi bro that that's blippi bro oh
look who that is so much worse than the
anal prolapse vid what the [__]
yo that's flippy that's straight doodoo
no it's like projectile [__] right on
his dude how did he do that they did
they did some preparation they took some
kind of supplements or something doo doo
that is the worst thing I've ever seen
that man pivoted from that to I'm gonna
make uh uh kids for Content wholesome uh
content yo that is insane dude less than
a year after this video he became blippi
that's a crazy pivot to do that in the
same year dude [__]
[__] on Twitter get mad at like
me wearing like uh make the rich pay
shirt way more than this which goes to
show you like everyone on Twitter is
permanently uh brain broken extremely
online and yet they only go after
whoever they know is on Twitter well
hold the [__] phone huh
in this video they say
it's undeniably unequivocally [__]
hilarious
about the blippi [__] video
in the in the article yeah oh I mean we
found it pretty funny so no no no no no
no that is I did not I did not find that
funny at all not not for the reason that
that is vile well it's right I guess
it's funny because it's blippy it's not
that's why right at the this is not
funny yeah not inherently I wouldn't
write this as it's disturbing yeah no I
get it I get it that's not that's not
funny so I'm questioning her credentials
now okay the story is actually pretty
funny though if you read through it an
attorney for Steven John sambus being
who's a seasoned desist letter asserting
his copyright on the video we've created
an artist rendition of a scene from it
below oh I want to see that can I show
this no no I I don't think you should do
that like blippi sent them a cease and
desist I think you should move away from
the story I think switch off Ian
this one
that's [__] awesome
yo that's awesome
[Laughter]
[__] blippy ass dumbass diarrhea
freak
I just I don't know I don't know what oh
God why did you teach me any of this
welcome to the show dude you want to be
part of the family or what oh everybody
in the audience has seen this stuff I
mean yeah that's gross and I feel bad
for them well that's part of the price
of Entry my friend it's so absurd oh
Jesus Christ all right so you wanna
let's move on I mean uh speaking of
diarrhea pudding Ron oh nice
nice three fingers there's a story uh
speaking of diarrhea
Rhonda Santos apparently puts three
fingers in a
in a little uh cup pudding cup and
Scoops it out and eats from his fingers
multiple accounts have reported that
pudding Ron has indeed done this yeah I
I thought I'm gonna have a controversial
take on the Super PAC ad that the Trump
uh Super PAC put out by the way what is
it mega war room or whatever yeah one of
those
let's run it first because Trump's
coming after him well so we've been
we've been wondering we've been guessing
what what's the nickname going to be
what's the I don't I don't really I I
don't know if uh I like to put in
fingers thing that much but well here it
is and uh I applaud them for certainly
taking this angle
need some audio there psycho and we're
not just talking to Santa's love
sticking his fingers where they don't
belong and we're not just talking about
pudding DeSantis has his Dirty Fingers
all over senior entitlements like
cutting Medicare slashing Social
Security
even raising our retirement I'm sorry
this is [__] awesome tell Ron
DeSantis to keep his pudding fingers
American politics and get this man a
spoon make America great again Inc is
responsible for the content of this
advertising Ron DeSantis so I think this
is like I mean the message is good
obviously like you know
don't Rhonda Santos wants to cut uh
benefits Social Security you know
entitlements
um that is going to play well with the
Republican base of old [__] who love
social security but hate like the nanny
state or whatever
um
however this is like a very Lincoln
project ass ad in my opinion okay
like the yeah maybe you're right it's
it's a bit corny uh it seems
I think maybe it's just two it's a
little too
silly
um no they they go with silly stuff all
the time I just think that this is a bit
up I don't know I don't know how to
describe it I feel like this is
something that the Lincoln project would
make about Donald Trump
um and I I think that the reason for
that is because Donald Trump has not
been given he's not been giving enough
uh uh he's not shown enough leadership
in like the [__] slinging game as he
used to
um which leads me to question whether or
not he still has it but you know every
now and then I see him in interviews and
his you know sassy side comes back out
but I agree he that he's not gone full
off on DeSantis yet I think he's waiting
he's waiting because DeSantis still
hasn't even you know
declared that he's running I think once
that happens then it's going to be it's
going to be War like I think saying
Marco Rubio is wet is like perfect uh
Donald Trump form
he used to make fun of uh Marco Rubio
for being moist oh because Marco Rubio
used to get sweaty on stage he's like
very nervous guy but then also there's a
racial component to it that people could
because you know
um he's Puerto Rican right well I I
don't I don't know what Margaret is but
yeah he's Latino so
um you know there is like that racial
element to it but
it's right up at the line so that like
people can say oh you're saying that
because you're being racist to Marco
Rubio who's Latino he's cute and then he
can turn around he's Cuban yeah and then
he can turn around and be like why are
you saying that I didn't say that that's
pretty good what I mean that that means
all wrong kind of Hitler and that's
exactly that's what I was gonna say
meatball Ron although that's just
straight Italian phobia yes but that's
fine nobody cares well it might be a
little fat phobia too right yeah it is
fine but what you it's not necessarily
about like saying a racial slur it's
more about getting the other side to
point to this being a racial slur and
getting them mad
that's what works really well because
then you have a lot of earned media and
also on top of that you can always say
look this is how the Liberals are
they're going crazy again I didn't mean
it like that but they're the ones who
are really racist for thinking I call
them n-word DeSantis
yeah but pretty much yeah
so
um I think uh he hasn't really done that
as much and he should get back to the
basics he's biting his time he's on it
dude yeah but the Santa is not looking
good he continues to Trend down and down
behind good old Trump
GOP Mega donors are dropping DeSantis
citing abortion and book bans what's
wrong with what's wrong with Banning
books and abortions in the whole state I
don't get the Panic uh so far yeah most
florid who reads anyway dude you know
what I mean this is what I say reading
yeah although I'm not quite sure what
this Mega donor was expecting in the
first place he's like Yo dude you went
too far this time
Banning books
it's always he's been doing that yeah
when he when they banned assassination
classroom uh in in the State of Florida
that was a bridge too far for Charlie so
I think he he's lost the he's lost the
Charlie Coalition oh that's huge he's
losing the Normie vote dude whoa uh
let's see I'll also forming a group Jews
against DeSantis oh no storm the stage
while I gave a speech in New Hampshire
not the Jews against DeSantis oh brother
if you look out of that organization by
the way that does not racist president
although I am a Jew you are wait you are
a Drew Pro uh you're
you're a Jews for Santa are you not
Jewish are you not visually a Jew
against DeSantis but I don't want to be
a member of any clubs or anything like
that oh okay I'm not [__] looking to
get any memos about being a part of a
Jewish club I'm not listen I'm
I don't want that I just don't want the
spam in your mouth no I don't want to be
part of the whole conspiracy where you I
don't when Jews group together make
clubs bad things are bad things are
gonna happen so I got nothing to do with
that yeah here's the thing
um first of all he's been losing a
little bit of weight I can tell oh yeah
he does look slim yeah uh it doesn't
matter though one too short
two how tall is he I think he's like
five ten or something short loser well I
mean for presidents yeah he would be
short
uh
uh is
what is what a surprise that link is
purple already when I looked it up
because I didn't click that uh it says
uh 511 on this website oh tall that's
definitely a lie I mean Trump lies about
his height too you know exactly and look
at this picture of them side by side not
much of a difference and Trump claims to
be like six fours Trump is six one no
Trump is it didn't it come out yeah when
he got arrested I think it was six one
yeah
270 pounds 350. no 270. but he's right
on Trump is right on the border of not
even be able to ride a horse
no Trump can't ride a horse Oh I thought
it was three it's 250. no no not even I
think it's 200. I can't ride a horse if
you're over 200. yeah I haven't been
able to ride a horse in years because
every time I every time I want to ride
one they're like you're too heavy well
hold on there's a lot of people over
200. that's that that's not fair yeah
that's why Nathan Fielder was right we
got to have these like massive balloons
strapped up to our big body
what if I got one of those like Goliath
[__] night horses like like uh was it
Clydesdale yeah well those are those
aren't even like riding horses I mean
you can ride them but they're they're
more so for like
you know pulling stuff whatever dude
I'll write it
I'll write it anyway I don't care here's
Jews for uh who Jews against this
Governor racist president racist 2010 12
14 16 18. yeah thank you
um
[Music]
I don't get this group uh the Jews
against us they might be like like you
gotta have a little Spice in the speech
right I mean you gotta have a little fun
he is so bad that's like
dude he is why do you want to pay the
ticket to get in just to do that I don't
know but Different Strokes for different
folks wait pause it pause it or it's
it's over anyway let me tell you
something okay that's the difference
between him and Donald Trump right there
it's perfectly captured in this uh in
this conference uh whatever when he's
like giving a speech in New Hampshire
okay he is so uncharismatic uh the
chapel boys uh already talked about this
extensively but it kind of burned into
the back of my mind as well now where uh
he's having a conversation with like
Pierce Morgan and addressing the rumors
on Fox news about the three pudding
finger thing and like his his counter to
that was like well it's sugar man like
that's that's what he said
and uh it is so is deeply uncharismatic
his defense oh he was he was justifying
it
like it's sugar man you need sugar yeah
shut up meanwhile Ron we've seen that
and it's like and and that's the thing
like first of all there's you know
sugar-free pudding uh secondly like the
idea that you know you're I'm watching
my weight you know that it's just like
wait you're a [__] loser Hassan
you're not gonna like this but DeSantis
actually just announced his running mate
oh come on
I don't even I never want to see this
[__] guy ever again I'm just saying
blippi has a pull with the child
demographic lots of parents like him I
do think it could be a a good uh pairing
here potentially for a vice president
yeah Rhonda Ron the groomer also has a
has a grasp on the younger demographics
let's go
oh okay uh that way yeah that's
traumatic when people rushed the stage
ahead of trump convention he gets all
weird and wild I love it I will call up
carrier the president I guess I have to
do it myself I know it's not
foreign
[Applause]
let's see how he recovers I want to see
what he says it's just this part there
that's actually quite athletic for this
big boy I'm gonna be honest but athletic
what did he do he just moved like 20.
playing
it's playing yeah
he recovers gracefully I don't even know
what happened someone rushed the stage
[Applause]
thank you for the warning I was ready
for him but it's much easier if the cops
do it
[Applause]
[Music]
I was ready for him
but it's much better when the cops do it
because I have to see look at that
that's rizz that's unspoken rizz I'm not
even kidding but it's just I don't know
the way he talks at the podium just gets
me I'm not like look Rhonda stands on
the other hand he's like oh I don't know
why someone would buy a ticket to do
that they're being strong for a
difference that's a little yeah
this is why he lost 22 points and all
the [__] dumbass polls in in New
Hampshire you know what I mean suck one
Ron bro you lost the Jews against
DeSantis people come on I mean seems
like they were against them from the
start Ethan I mean another organization
I was hyper specific but I'm not with
them I want to be very clear about that
no like are they Jews for Trump then
like if they're against DeSantis like
what is the distinguishing factor
between Rhonda Sanders and Donald Trump
I don't really understand I'm not a part
of that group don't ask me
you really don't want any associate yeah
[__] no address the Jews against the
Iran people have a tendency to Clump
juice together I just want to make it
very clear
I'm one Jew no Club yeah you know who
did that last time Adolf Hitler that's
it I'm just a man yeah I I agree oh
associated with anything
yeah I mind my business and that's
[__] it no memos
I'm not friends okay now you're just
addressing it too much I mean uh
wojinski is gone yeah he's gone it kind
of feels like there is
uh I've never talked to George Soros in
my life
how did we buy this 20 billion dollar
compound you never really mentioned
like where the money came from no I did
it was from the um
it was uh it was a settlement from Cav
cab for earlier
interesting a convincing cover story
yeah yeah so Trump dropped some new nfts
by the way which I love oh dude fire I
missed the drop dude
and as as somehow
I'm not surprised to know that his fans
are such
suckers that he sold all of them
apparently there was uh there was 47
cards you could buy no no there were 99
per and he said if you buy 47 cards 4
700 I don't know why that number you get
dinner with Trump because he's going to
be re-elected as the 47th president okay
I think they've given up the whole he's
technically still president thing and
this man has never had one of those
dinners I don't believe it I think they
all get together and he just like says
whatever no shot I don't even think that
happens I don't think he shows up
[__]
I mean you are the biggest sucker if
you're buying a trump nft so well I
definitely wouldn't think I'm having a
one if you think you're having a
one-on-one with Trump for 4 600 you're a
dumb [__] idiot loser Lindsay uh he
says as of 10 minutes ago my digital
Trading Card sold out and in record time
approximately 4.6 million a great honor
what record
it's a record what's the record yeah
it's a record for it's like compared to
what like the second Trump nft drop
the fastest it's ever sold I guess maybe
it's faster than the first one
I'm sure it's made up yeah because it's
a great honor and I hope everyone is
happy healthy and Wealthy
congratulations
so let's take a look at some of these
you deserve it if you if you're getting
duped by Donald Trump to buy one of his
[__] nfts and you don't even have to
disposable income and you're just like
you know putting a second mortgage on
the house or whatever you [__]
deserve it you clown please show these
whoa you're stealing them Yo nobody
screenshots any of these nfts please
you're not recording are you Ian 99 a
piece you guys
as you guys know he is a rock and roller
I love how hot they make him in all of
these barbecue he's like a bit yassified
what is that the lion one that's sick
dude lion yeah why the lion it's almost
like uh king of the jungle
he's a lion one that's [__] weird
yeah so here it is guys it's really
embarrassing to own one of these Frank
wait so are there not there's not 47
different ones are there no you didn't
know
is that a crossbow yeah I think so yeah
yeah
it's not an AR-15 yeah it's just a
crossbow he's pro gun control
Trump doesn't even like dogs like famous
he hates dogs
I got a black glass isn't this like a
Rastafarian thing the lightning or the
lion imagery Snoop line remember we went
by that for like a day yeah they do use
some of that sometimes they're not the
only one though I was reading an article
the guitar Community is pissed off at
the uh one where he's holding the guitar
because the uh the the way it's crafted
is completely wrong it would never be
yeah I'm pissed about this yeah
I voted for Donald Trump and uh and I
and I would do it again and I actually
illegally voted for Donald Trump
multiple times right oh yeah and as a
guitar Aficionado a guitar head
um you know this is the final draw final
straw for me okay this is this is just
not safe playing guitar while you're on
a motorcycle I mean that's silly yeah
well you know safeties for [__] dude
what do you mean Trump is a big badass
so congratulations anyway to all the
lucky owners of this limited time uh
investment I'm sure it's gonna bring you
lots of wealth
and lots of happiness
[Applause]
um okay I'm gonna pee real quick while
you stay on this don't move on to the
next one please yet you want me to talk
more about Trump
well apparently this level of grifting
is actually upsetting some of his
supporters no no no no
uh Baked Alaska he's he's one of these I
don't know who is that guy uh he has
really fallen off in the last few years
uh partially because he spent some time
in jail for uh in the capital on January
6th he was famously the one that was
streaming them in Nancy Pelosi I think
it was Pelosi's office yeah I'm pretty
sure that's right
um not the brightest guy uh I would
compare him to the dude that we were
talking about on the show yesterday
um right uh Eric Ethan Ethan Schmidt
Ethan Schmidt um where he was just kind
of a troll he would live stream himself
going around and just harassing people
being an [__] generally and uh yeah
he was a hardcore Maga guy but um the
nfts may have been
or maybe the prison he says I can't
believe I went to prison for an nft
sales
it's starting to set in uh for baked
Alaska
maybe I backed the wrong man he was
thinking to himself from a prison cell
yeah but uh who knows who knows that
remains to be seen
um
I'll watch this video well
what we got it's the NRA diversity one
oh yeah yeah as you you guys the NRA a
powerful organization a lot of people
think of it as like a white Christian
kind of organization in general
but um this speaker Governor uh Christie
gnome
South Dakota
is here to ensure us that diversity is
at the heart of the NRA and here's her
speech about it
a lot of other people
a lot of diversity within the NRA well
let me tell you something I may be a mom
and a grandma but I am she's a grandma
yo
that's crazy a lot of diversity so as
she was saying lots of diversity uh in
the NRA
and as you can see uh
here's a little slice of there of their
membership and as you can tell they have
uh old white Christians they have uh
middle aged white Christians
they have um
uh old white women Christians also
they've got uh middle aged white uh
Christians with beards C-SPAN did them
dirty beards they did not have to pan to
the [__] most Caucasian audience of
all time I like to think that the tech
director at C-SPAN did this
intentionally because it's so [__]
bro they pan over and like this
demographic like the diversity here is
what like the age range of of 65 to 85
like what the [__] going on look how
diverse we are brother we got you know
Hank here is actually 60 years old he's
totally outside of the demographic well
what's interesting about the NRA
conventions they actually start them
real early so that they can get out in
time for the early bird specialist bill
it's baked in there
4 P.M dinner at Denny's yes right it's a
good discount yeah it's worth it
yes by the way here these are the people
that want kids to continue dying so that
they can own AR for 15. just take a look
into their [__] Souls they all love
Jesus man
nothing says Jesus like a egg like an
AR-15 yeah dead kids guess what as
Marjorie Taylor green famously said if
Jesus Christ had weapons of war at his
disposal the Roman government would not
have been able to crucify him
she did say that and I agree with her if
Jesus is making good points if Jesus had
modern day Arsenal he could have stopped
the Romans which begs the question if
the man is all-powerful God I mean why
didn't he you know because that was the
point and that's and why are they mad
exactly that's what why what MTG is
saying is so insane it's like it would
have been badass if he didn't die for
our sins they can't get the story
straight it was it good was it not was
it on purpose was it not I mean guys
come on now anyway let's take a look
that's right the even the Applause
sounds White
[Laughter]
somehow somehow you're right
so that was pretty funny little goof
there
um
a new shabibo soy face dropped Hassan
pretty exciting I don't know if you saw
this for the record uh Christy gnome is
51 years old and she's a grandmother
Lauren bobert is 36 and she's a
grandmother oh my God what how what the
[__] yeah low end Lauren bobert Lobo is
a grandma at 36. so hold on hold the
phone
let me crush the numbers on there yeah
do the numbers don't make sense dude
math Baby You're Gonna figure it out oh
I I think if she was a teen pregnancy
and then uh her kid was also a teen
pregnancy that's right that's pretty
much the only way that that would happen
her 17 year old son is expecting a baby
with his teenage girlfriend in April yep
anyway here's Ben Shapiro doing soy face
uh Mr Beast vs trans conservation this
this [__] video made me so mad one
because it's like just straight
plagiarizing Sunny V2
identical he literally sang the same
[__] honeybee too the Highlight secondly
titled the same way as Sonny's yeah this
is the main yeah that's secondly it
looks like he's in support of Chris uh
you know yeah coming out
I love it yeah hypothetically turned him
gay I wonder if I wonder if Ben Shapiro
continually makes his eyebrows look
thicker because he thinks well folks Mr
Beast is to draw attention away from his
patchy ass awful ass uh you know Little
Beard that he's trying to grow
anyway so that's that little nice little
shout out there but let's move on to
Matt Walsh hacked another fine member of
the daily wire uh
this was fantastic
um of course they got it resolved
immediately my first impulse was they're
never gonna get this fixed because
nobody works with Twitter anywhere but
of course Elon Musk is going to help
them yeah what do you mean yeah that
that like you know uh what is it Anya
Taylor Joy is that her name am I saying
that right no
Queen's Gambit chick yes yeah
um she's great uh she was selling
laptops for like a month really uh David
Dan
was like Bobby Lee's been selling
laptops for like two years
on Twitter yeah like literally so many
so many celebrity accounts and even
journalists like David Dan have been
hacked a million times over and they're
they dude they fixed this [__] in like
an hour they not only fixed it but they
immediately deleted laptops nine more
left I know he could sell out today guys
that's so [__] funny yeah holy [__]
well someone needs to buy those nine
laptops so Bobby can get his [__]
account back
um oh that's so funny anyway
what I'm trying to say is uh yes of
course if you are a horrifically violent
bigoted transphobic psychopath Elon Musk
loves you and will literally give you
you know uh absolutely White Glove
service not the right term yeah white
glove service yeah like personally and
individually he will defend your account
which he did
um so here's he says my my pronouns are
that n-word yeah that was the first
tweet where we're like okay interesting
Matt Walsh
uh my Twitter isn't hacked this is just
the real me coming out apparently so
what happened was and this is almost
happened to me they got uh Sim swap a
Sim swap yeah pretty classic yeah pretty
classic yeah it's scary that that's so
easy to do still yeah I don't know if
you remember that almost happened to me
like a a long it was a long time people
were saying yeah they thought I saw I
lost because it was happening to a lot
of YouTubers so I was like on high alert
and I saw that my reception my service
dropped out completely
and I was like oh [__] dude somebody has
my I was my fear so I called in and I
got it uh
I got in just in time bro yeah
they've um they've tried to do that to
me as well
um it's it's super common
and even when I tried to call my carrier
and put in some like fail safes
and like PIN codes
they were like the the representatives
there are so untrained
these guys they call and call and call
so many times they find someone who
[__] it up they ultimately always have
they they usually have like one guy
inside too like a guy with access that's
it they always have like a low-level guy
pin number right yeah they actually knew
my PIN number yeah so I was like there
there's no prediction from this
yeah
but anyway so yeah he hacked them
uh there's more tweets here you know
what you did you are Ben Shapiro you
know what you did you were a closeted
homosexual and hide behind being Jewish
that is something Matt Walsh would say
if he was not an employee of his
um I can confirm Andrew Tate at
covertake can happen and rape those
girls right Joe Rogan is a pedophile I
ain't a gangster I'm a sassy shooter
I'm league in the DM soon no cash this
is the one that I really like I hope he
exported all those DMS and I can't wait
to see that was the last one before uh
the account got locked down yeah they
locked it down there's a so a couple
things happened in this process
um
a wired editor uh a wired journalist
actually
uh went after
the hacker
and uh and and wanted to write an
article about it right
uh which is what journalists do
understandably this is like a massively
famous uh far right
stochastic terrorist public figure
whatever you want to [__] call them
and
um his [__] got compromised so
soliciting hacked material
of this variety
is technically not illegal even though
Matt Walsh wants it to be yeah this is
like this is what journals are supposed
to do obviously they will not
uh reveal information that uh is is
private you know your family members
things of that nature or your address is
like they're not supposed to do that but
that's true uh media wouldn't be able to
report on any government leak exactly
never heard of WikiLeaks
Pentagon Papers exactly whatever it's
stupid it's obscene so here's what
happened
um the journalists that actually went
and and uh you know talked to the hacker
had his Twitter account needed so the
white glove service even extends to
people who are trying to solicit
information or write articles
on uh Matt Walsh's account being hacked
so Elon banned the reporter
so he's pretty keyed into this yeah
Bobby Lee's been selling uh laptops for
two years but uh yeah Matt Walsh has his
captive captive uh if you want if you
want immediate attention from Elon Musk
you just gotta be like a horrifically
violent uh anti-trans bigot yeah I mean
Elon Musk is really showing
I didn't expect that he was this vial in
terms of like his beliefs but he's
really allowing himself with the the
daily wire folks which is really scary
and disturbing as they're like the most
hateful almost genocidal [__] maniacs
uh today I think yeah
yeah I mean not almost yeah they they
are genocidal but there is something
good that came out of this uh the hacker
did post um
uh a song called sassy Shooters which he
was trying to promote yeah this was
friends uh song I think or something and
so I just want to say that um
uh dropped the DMS brother here's sassy
shooters
drop the DMs
[Music]
DM
drop the DMS dude
[Music]
yeah and his 117k plays yeah 50 likes
only that's a little bit low I think uh
you know they deserve more I don't know
if people still have SoundCloud the
memberships been around the block cause
your dick sucked is a bar I mean that's
fire
so yes shout out and
um's brother release the DMS please
thank you so anyway
um you know the the article itself is
actually quite informative uh
unfortunately the DMS don't seem it
won't won't be released anytime soon
um the hack was accomplished Doom says
using a technique known as Sim swapping
so we were correct on that and
um basically he said he just did it for
a meme like he didn't do it for any
political reason just to like troll a
little bit and he he sent some uh emails
between Walsh and Crowder
uh Crowder introducing himself before he
and Walsh begin opining about the
imminent collapse of cable news industry
uh and then the growing obsolescence of
talk radio and Matt Walsh basically says
uh you know he's talking about shrinking
market shares and he's a radio host at
the time
um he says that his primary goal is
growing his personal brand for profit he
says there's certainly plenty of money
to be made when you can get millions of
hits online and I'm a capitalist and I
have a family so I've decided to start
getting serious about that if I said
that people would just go so
anti-semitic on me yeah right my only
goal here is to make as much money as
possible and grow your personal brand
you're your Captain by the way you
noticed it wasn't I want to spread
Christian Gospel I want to uh uh I want
to spread a conservative Doctrine
because I think it's what the world
needs no it's I want to make as much
[__] money as possible
and boy he chose the right vertical for
that
yeah he's uh I mean he's a he's an
absolute freak although I will say
Hassan uh he dirt when the hack took
place he was giving a speech uh at Iowa
University com whining and complaining
that YouTube completely demonetizes his
channel due to his transphobic coverage
of Dylan Mulvaney uh and he claims at
least that he was getting a hundred
thousand dollars a month
from YouTube
which going over his videos frankly I'll
show you something really uh sad and
disturbing about Matt Walsh who is the
most hateful [__] [__] ass
so before his like transphobic Crusade
on
um Dylan
[Music]
his views were consistently dog [__]
like nobody cared about Matt Walsh even
if you go as far back as two weeks ago
eighty eight thousand forty thousand
yikes eighty thousand but once he starts
hitting this transphobic here it is
let's see eight hundred thousand five
hundred thousand like the views are
crazy every single video's got like
1.1 million Bud Light the Bud Light [__]
and now he's post all his videos look at
this he made the dumbest video about
blippi by the way he didn't even mention
the diarrhea [__] uh 650. 850. wait
his video criticizing blippi wasn't
about to die oh yeah no I watched it on
the member stream it's so vapid let me
show you let me show you what his thesis
was against blippi what did he thinks
he's like gay or something right no no
he doesn't so let me just show you he
doesn't
he doesn't support it at all he goes
watch this hold on hold on okay
watch this
my family and you can do the same text
Walls to get a free info kit on gold
today with an A plus rating With Better
Business thousands of happy customers
and countless five star reviews Birch
gold is the company I trust to protect
my future and yours text Walls to
9898-98 today gold
now a lot of blippi content consists of
John who's the original blippi
um
running around playgrounds like he's
mentally disabled uh here's here's one
of the most popular videos on the
channel this this video has garnered he
reviews it as if it's meant to be
consumed by full-grown adults
that's like Dude okay first of all this
is like 80 of daily wire content if you
haven't noticed they always look at like
whatever the [__] children are supposed
to be watching and then they
meticulously break it down with the
veracity of like a [__] unboxing
YouTuber where they're like soy facing
half the time and if Disney is not
giving them like enough gay content they
will literally make up Disney shows that
don't even exist yet and then get mad at
that hypothetical it is so pathetic like
you saw the Ben Shapiro video I'm sure
on Twitter that was going viral or he's
like Frozen Four Elsa is going to be
super gay like oh yeah it's like dude
that never you're literally fantasizing
about a movie that hasn't come out like
that that is not even in like
development or anything to get angry at
that movie it's so [__] transparent
what these guys are doing well
there's a market tell me what you think
about this analysis 500 million okay
that's half a billion views and almost
all those views coming from kids who are
like please
here's this clip that is so disturbing
this is the best they could find hey
hey it's me blippi and it's night time
and we're in a parking lot there's so
many stores
wow look at this store it's the
Kinderland indoor playground in Las
Vegas Nevada come on hi
hold on watch it in its entirety it is
weird though like I mean he's he's not
wrong I can't believe I'm saying this
but he's like where's my shoes it's not
weird at all dude if you have kids this
is like not [__] weird at all dude
Matt Walsh probably responds to Dora
when she asks questions he's like yeah
don't he's like it's so obvious it's
blue
blue this Show's so easy what are you
doing Dora
it's not weird at all dude it's actually
pretty good kids content in terms of the
other [__] that's out there
so blippi is even certified that's what
we're finding out without I mean yeah
without the diarrhea [__] I think it's
constant is good
[Music]
now because like there's so much bad
kids content especially online his
stuff's at least like um
educational you know thoughtful like
pretty good vibe wholesome play
so this clip
and Shadow on his friend yeah that he
didn't mention that that would have been
good
also a gay act some would say
that's a slam dunk
hello so there it is I mean that's
enough of that
um he's very upset by that huh I don't
mean to overstate this but I would
rather jump feet first into a wood
chipper than continue watching that yeah
yeah it's not for you you [__] free
why you don't he's sitting by himself
watching blippi and being like I don't
get it just angrily angrily tuning into
like YouTube kids opening up my YouTube
kids subscription just the froth out of
the mouth at like whatever the next
blippi video is oh my God he unboxed
Kinder Surprise
oh it made me so angry yeah if those
hackers happen to see this by the way
they're looking for some cover art for
sassy Shooters we have you covered so
here's the thing
Matt Walsh got his account back and the
first thing he did was change his bio
back to Theocratic fascists yeah like
which is way less offensive he literally
was like oh yeah no time to get my time
to time to get my ducks in a row you
know time to get my business in check
here let me type out that I'm a
Theocratic fascist again in my [__]
bio but Freakazoid dude no that's great
I mean that's cool that's good that
feels comfortable he's so
gross he does one more reason and awful
which is why it's just it's it's obvious
what this is right people only watch him
because he's transphobic and they want
to hear transphobic [__] because they're
just as transphobic as he is maybe not
as much uh it's hard to be as
transferable because Matt Walsh but
that's it that's the whole point like
there he's not charismatic he's not
unique he's not funny he's not creative
oh he's got nothing his jokes are
horrible his analysis is total nonsense
I mean here watch this he shows another
clip there's literally no analysis
there's no explanation for why he's
feeling the way he is and it left me
utterly stunned and Confused that this
is watchable content no offense to
blippi and that's a video from five
years ago but the newer blippi content
is exactly like this of course it is
because you got 500 million views on
this this is children's content
created by a weirdo degenerate through
an album he didn't even mention the
diarrhea thing that would have worked if
he mentioned the diarrhea then I go yes
he's a weirdo degenerate but he has not
given any context okay that's that's
what this is he's a weirdo degenerate
simply because he entertains kids which
Matt Walsh doesn't believe in by the way
only
that's the only book that my kids are
allowed to read there's a video from
five days ago which features the new
blippi in exactly the same sort of
situation let's watch some of that
so much
[Music]
hey it's me and it's me
and today we're at Candyland indoor
playground in Sherman Oaks
oh they think it's like gay because it's
Candy Land
because there's a black person in it
miscegenation brother he doesn't say it
yeah you normally want to start your day
with breakfast but
today is opposite day so let's start it
with dinner because breakfast and dinner
are opposite hey I saw Supermarket back
there let's dance backwards okay let's
go find some cookies you got that off
[Music]
listen to how dramatic he is
um
now again I'm not trying to be insulting
the bloody but all I will say is that
these videos make me long for the sweet
release of death and on the plus side
I've actually overcome my fear of my own
mortality just by watching short clips
of blippi it made me realize there are
some things worse than death
and again bro it's like
it's like the amount yeah the the amount
he's like for three year olds I mean I
guess he's trying to he's trying to cut
content you know he's trying to get in
the algo meanwhile I'm trying to change
my username now that I've lost my blue
check mark I think I'm gonna change it
yeah I won't change your mind to Elon
Musk no not your you know you can change
your
the handle yeah you can change that you
can change your hand wait why would you
want to do that no no
you not the at you mean the at yeah oh I
want to change the ass switch it up
I do want to become Elon Musk though
although can I still get banned even if
I'm not verified for doing that or is it
only people who are verified I think it
was just verified in fact you know he'll
ban yeah I mean and so be it if so
I I agree I mean Twitter's just it's so
bad it's a rat hole it is I mean really
never mind I can't change it because of
course both of those usernames are taken
uh surprising
here we we got a small correction on the
uh
on the album art oh thank God yeah use
that this dude I heard that Matt Walsh
uh while watching Blue's Clues once
um punched a hole through the wall yeah
uh his his hand is he couldn't figure
out the clues it's just yeah it was too
hard too hard that [__] die is lying
dogs can't talk everybody knows this
what the [__]
this is insane like is this really what
are teaching our kids that dogs can talk
what the [__] did blue actually talk
blue never talked about yeah yeah well
thank you a crime-solving dog what's
next
what's next a trans who drinks Bud Light
trans person drinks Bud Light [__]
[__]
yeah so uh Matt Walsh uh
that's about it eh
wait there is a really juicy detail
unless I missed it when I stepped away
for a second about his contract with
daily wire
um oh that was there was something
leaked about that well so remember when
Crowder had his war with daily wire a
couple months ago yeah he leaked the
contracts in like his conversations with
them and one of his biggest things was
that their their standard contract was
that if you get demonetized on YouTube
they cut your pay by 25 which did happen
that was the biggest sticking point to
Crowder it was like [__] that because if
YouTube demonetized me I'm not taking a
pay cut so Matt Walsh getting
demonetized on YouTube not only loses
him the AdSense Revenue but likely
is going to lose him money from daily
wire as well
assuming the daily wire that he they got
to be sharing with daily wire
no no remember the the Steven Crowder so
what did they like the deal the Stephen
Crowder deal is that like
um the the daily wire cuts his pay if he
gets demonetized or if he gets banned
yeah which makes sense because they're
getting his YouTube Revenue
it goes yeah
they give them a guaranteed right he got
and he had to give them a percentage of
that or whatever and they take
everything I'm assuming right and then
it's mind-boggling to me that Matt Walsh
was making 100 Grand a month off YouTube
by just doing almost exclusively hate
speech right yeah very profitable any
other subgroup that mount Walsh targets
to this degree
um like if it was about gay people even
for example YouTube would be like okay
that's like this is crazy but because
it's trans people
um there is uh discussion surrounding
them so you can be as transphobic as you
want to be fair that is why his entire
Channel got demonetized like permanently
demonetized or no that's not no he
didn't get permanently he said as long
as I remove the videos I can get
monetization back yeah
yeah and it's because uh he's like
regularly misgendering Dylan Mulvaney
not when
he uh basically Justified the Q
nightclub shootings
or uh uh fantasized about like uh drag
queens being beat up by cops not when he
uh you know talked about or lied about
the Children's Hospital in Boston like
that's some real villain [__] dude when
you're like when your main uh enemies in
your commentary is a [__] Children's
Hospital it's like
like you're out of control yeah uh
YouTube's like nah that stuff's great we
love that thank you thank you Matt Walsh
keep making that great content please
and it goes to show you once again
um there's a lot of money to be made in
hateful content and hateful commentary
there's a lot of like freaks online who
are extremely online that don't
represent uh a broader base of support
in the voters that uh really really love
this [__] it's uh that's why I say like
transphobia is a mental illness like
actually a mental illness when you
become transphobic or I guess everyone's
starting point is a little transphobic
regardless
um the way I describe it is like I put
it into three brackets okay most
people's starting position is you know
transphobia because of the way that
we've learned about gender and how
deeply personal it is to our identity is
a core part of it right it's rigid it's
this rigid binary and um for that reason
the normative position for the most part
can we not call that transphobic you
know what I mean I feel like that the
Norman that doesn't do the move the
acceptance movement regardless the
normative position is apathy right the
overwhelming majority of the public
looks at trans people and goes yeah
that's kind of weird I don't really get
it whatever right yes it's weird I don't
really understand it who cares that's
that's usually the the apathy is the
normative position this is what trans
activists says well it's not just me
saying this uh and then there's two
different brackets you have the other
people who see that and uh you know are
faced with trans people in their
personal lives or anything like that and
then they are no longer transphobic
they're against transphobia which is a
not as big as a subgroup obviously but
still you know relatively sizable
um and then you have trans people
themselves obviously and then the last
category is the transphobic people who
see that and then make a decision to
actively become transphobic where
they're like no this is really [__] up
we need to put an end to this this is
destroying western civilization and when
you go down that rabbit hole the
starting point could be something as uh
seemingly innocuous as like I don't
think that trans women should compete
with CIS women in athletic competitions
uh all the way down to you know uh trans
people are all groomers and and
pedophiles and all this sort of stuff
and then the final stage of that Mania
is seeing trans people everywhere you go
where you think anyone and everyone is
trans where you become a transvestigator
that's what it's called yeah
transvestigations where you are
investigating gender uh the and and
whether or not every everyone around you
is is secretly trans and the reason why
that's really funny is because it
literally it reconfirms the reality that
gender is an expression and it's a
social construct and it's actually not
as rigid as you think it is because you
start thinking like CIS women who are
pregnant like [__] Daniel Radcliffe's
wife is actually secretly trans
and when you get to that point though we
can always tell crowd is routinely
misgendering CIS women over and over
again they start misgendering
um they start misgendering uh CIS men
over and over again because guess what
you can't always tell because gender is
a social construct it is basically like
a like a sock that you put on top of
your foot if you want to consider like
the biological gender or sex which also
isn't a rigid binary in the way that
people uh think it is but it's something
that you wear on top of that
right it's your it's your outwards
expression so people believe that his
girlfriend is trans
who is pregnant dude that's good oh so
they admit that um trans people can get
pregnant well that's the that's the
hilarity is that like it basically is
gender abolition but from the other side
of the argument when you become so
transphobic that you think everyone
around you is trans you are basically
engaging in this weird uh uh you know
right-wing gender abolition where this
is crazy let me see the what what
exactly how are they walking that
expresses a triangle I think it's that
their shoulders are not Square enough
like a man yeah and uh honestly I don't
I don't understand the triangle like I
can't that's like just how pants work
bro that's where the [__] is brother
yeah I'm not sure what's being like
targeted here yeah
and um I I like the joke about this but
like uh the final stage of
transvestigations is when you think that
like your parents are secretly trans
actually because like some of them do
get to this level because they become
more and more like unhinged they're
becoming like delusional right like it's
delirium it's a it's a it's literally a
paranoia personality disorder and these
people find each other on the internet
yeah but it's like it's it's something
that you basically broke your brain into
uh believer and uh my joke is that the
the last last stage of transvestigation
is when you think you are uh you were
trans when you were a baby but you just
by your transparents your parents are
secretly trans they're not CIS and you
were trans than an early age serious is
it elon's feminine spine is evidence
what what
feminine spine I love Ryan Gosling
because gay v-shaped clavicle equals
female
uh uh oh they're all men
yeah
squared off jaw they they're a man okay
okay interesting
this is science this is very scientific
I can tell they really uh
yeah analyze this and then they
misgender these people too like he's so
rectangular it's like
yeah let me analyze pictures of you bro
whoever put this together let me analyze
pictures of you well you would do that
uh you would say that except I'm pretty
sure this Mel article actually gets into
that as well transvestigation
communities on Facebook have been
wrought with controversy not because you
know they're doing something Freak Like
but because they actually end up having
fallouts because they start accusing one
another of being trans or awesome
hahaha
yeah um the way that I think about it
and this is how I think about most of
these social issues is that
at the end of the day you're either in
favor of
freedom for people to be who they want
to love who they want
and supporting people's Pursuit of
Happiness which is supposed to be a
god-given and constitutional right
or
you are in favor of um
you know projecting your
world view onto other people and forcing
people to live in a way that that you
approve of
yeah ironically it's like they say about
one or the other it's just one or the
other they say that about trans people
existing even though that's literally
what the anti-trans folks are doing
they claim that trans people want
everyone to be trans they want us to
subscribe to their belief system it's
like no man they just want to be left
alone dog they want to be able to get
their medical procedures and they want
to be [__] left alone to you know
um keep playing the hearts of iron and
Crusader Kings and [__] you know every
Paradox game that comes out in that and
I just as a big Paradox game fan myself
I played Crusaders what the [__] you
said that last week too although what's
the what's the problem the trans people
want to play it no but he but I promise
those games are for me unplayable I like
Crusaders yeah the the kind of neuro
atypicality I have is specifically
towards trains and
um and and so it doesn't pertain to
Paradox games for some reason I tried
playing it literally uh supply lines you
you build trains just so you know you
build I know but I want you to see the
trains I want to see these like big
monstrous you know uh steel vehicles I
understand
yeah but at any rate uh we were talking
about how these guys are kind of blaming
the victims and all this [__] and
Crowder again who is I think monetized
on YouTube or well no he's gone right
he's off YouTube I'm [__] know it
goes back and forth he's always talking
about it my man's kind of falling off
I'm not gonna lie yeah
well I don't know what you're talking
about that dude is worth
over 40 million a year brother
fight like hell mug club uh he with
dream Brewer I mean he streamed three
hours ago so I guess
yeah four hours he's still up on YouTube
well so YouTube is allowing this kind of
speech to continue I'm gonna show you
this clip this is the story about his
live streams get like
132k views on the vods he has fallen off
a little bit well how long has it been
up
bro a day
let me let me pull it up I I just click
on his live tab one day ago 132k views
three days ago 162k views two days ago
163k views
what is his Rumble views like if we can
get it
they've been really high yeah let's I
don't know how reliable what are what
are his Rumble views like okay well what
are his made-up views like in his mind
right because there's people aren't
actually watching like we know enough
about YouTube people on YouTube are oh
they will not go follow you to another
platform for the most part because yeah
if you go to rumble they sing his and
Rumble itself a million views and Rumble
itself doesn't have enough active
viewership to like justify having that
kind of a Magic Spike for one particular
content creator over the other
one little trick is always to look at
the second third fourth largest channels
on on any particular platform to see
like whether or not there's a lot of
activity going on ninja went from twitch
to mixer mixer is a legit website owned
by Microsoft right he went to make sir
his audience drop-off was severe how do
we know that how do we know that those
views were legit or um because his
audience drop off was severe when you
ever whenever you see someone go from
one platform to another in that in that
platform they're getting like way more
views and it's like you know kick or or
rumble or or getter or any number of
these different platforms where they
like are actively most likely yeah
um
you will see them get more viewership uh
but then you look at like uh you look at
the the second largest guy and he's got
like 20 [__] views you know what I
mean yeah
um but yeah I mean like you were saying
his views are pretty bad I mean our show
actively gets like I would say
five to six times these views per
episode and I'm not worth I don't get
where's my 40 million dollar per year uh
well you just uh you know say some
transphobic [__]
real quick
by the way Hassan eat this oh my God
[Music]
I agree
awesome bro
also are you going skiing what the [__]
it looks sunny
why are you wearing like fortnite
goggles those are those are the
non-falloff shades dude those are the
hater Shades brother Balenciaga yeah
that's so I don't think falling off
means you're broke by the way you're
missing the point yeah I mean look look
it clearly you know his braless wife is
about to bring him a sandwich that he
didn't ask for by the way that's Utopia
man yeah right there on the plane so
okay so here's a clip of crowder this is
great this is on YouTube with Jim Brewer
uh world famous comedian now uh turned
over they replaced the leprechaun with
him yeah what happened to my boy
they didn't say they just they booted
him it's kind of sad I agree they threw
him out like I'm doing all right dude I
mean
sorry is that offensive to the ladies
throw them out like a used tampon
or do perf I mean you do throw them out
it just I like the image of him being
what do you think women carry do you
think they're tampons however they use
them like what the [__] I'm saying is it
offensive that I'm invoke like a used
tampon because I mean it's I don't use
tampons I mean it's more vulgar but it
doesn't what about a used I don't find
that my used tampons have any value to
me I love trying to understand how your
mind works
what is controversial and what's not
listen I I don't use tampons I don't
know if some women might be like feel
targeted because I'm saying used tampons
like it's gross you'll be hypersensitive
about this particular thing but then
you'll say something insane and be like
what what's wrong I don't understand
look because like a joke about like B
wording the N uh Place
yeah is like so in my opinion no that
wasn't what I was referencing anyway
let's just move on yeah maybe it's not
test the button today you know whatever
yeah you're not the only one by the way
but anyway here's Crowder Ralph Yar yarl
it was a 16 year old black kid who went
to the wrong house looking for his
sister picking up his sister no his twin
brother twin brother younger sister I
think you might be both right I thought
it was siblings plural that he was
picking oh okay anyways and uh the guy
who this old white dude who lived there
just [__] killed him he just said hey
dude he survived oh he shot him he's so
he just shot him twice in the head and
and shoulder I believe but uh in some he
miraculously survived and was was he
shot his head once and then he fell to
the ground and then he shot him in the
arm so he shot him twice once while he
was on the ground and of course this is
a apparently considered legal uh uh in
Missouri
because you must be able to defend
yourself in your home the castle
doctrine
oh people are gonna get mad at you
because you said Missouri
wasn't it in
says
very law
wait I thought wait hold up okay so
there were a bunch of incidents like
this oh yeah you're right it was in
Missouri you're right yeah
so he shot the kid in the head and he
survived
yeah crazy I mean obviously he's gonna
have a lifelong medical problems I'm
sure like no not really but by the way
at least he survived look at the picture
of this [__] guy who did it look at
that guy he is okay so arm this guy so
let's arm him so let's get into it first
of all uh right off the bat as soon as
the news came out uh over the weekend
that they that the media immediately
lied and said they kept him in detention
for 24 hours that's [__] oh they
can't let him go no they talked to him
for two hours and then they'd let him go
he's this man's shot yeah a 16 year old
boy in the head when I found out I sleep
at home yeah and when I found that out
immediately I was like this is a [__]
old racist guy who has a gun who's out
of his [__] mind from like watching a
shitload of Fox News and and you know
all these like conspiracy theories that
he gets on Facebook and on the Internet
or whatever
um and I was right 85 84 years old
um Andrew Lester uh a white Homer owner
in uh what they consider the
neighborhood to be like a bit of a
Sundown neighborhood I guess uh went
shot uh Ralph Yar yarl a black teenager
who's 16 years old and the cops
basically questioned him for like a
little bit and then they were like well
this is an old guy you know he's a good
old boy he's a good old man he was
afraid yeah his grandson actually came
out recently and uh talked to a Kansas
newspaper as a matter of fact and said
and this will be a surprise to no one
that his grandfather has become a
delusional person from watching a [__]
ton of right-wing media became like an
anti-vaxxer a conspiracy theorist and of
course he owns a gun and is [__] you
know perpetually terrified of black
people coming into his neighborhood why
I wonder how he got this uh idea that
like black people are coming to get him
and you know steal his home or whatever
perhaps local news owned by Sinclair
broadcasting and Fox News has to do with
it you know Fox News maybe an
a-o-n-r-o-a-n yeah but so now that we've
set it up so here's crap router's
response okay let's see let's see you
guys um how where's he gonna take this
doesn't mean that Lester is a racist
exactly it could still mean that he saw
a strange man right you know jiggling
the handle on his door trying to get in
he didn't know what was going on got
scared and maybe he made a mistake yeah
it's all those things are possible even
Ralph the kid he's a street kid right if
I'm a street kid and I'm at a door and I
see a white older man approaching and
clearly I could tell if he's stressed I
would say
yeah I may be at the wrong I'm looking
for my little brother yeah yeah I mean
there's a lot of elements but you're
hitting on a subject where yeah so
according to them it was actually uh the
six-year-old boy who [__] up who
should have been more guarded yeah he
should have re and by the way we don't
know what happened yeah I mean we
probably saw a gun and did all the
things they're saying if you're a black
kid if you're a 16 year old black kid
like you should wear Kevlar everywhere
you go because like you know everyone
has a gun people are [__] terrified
they're gonna shoot you like you [__]
up you should definitely always wear a
Kevlar best by the way this is the
street kid uh they're referring to
it's like dude this kid's been
apparently asked according to his mom uh
by uh Yale twice he's like a super uh
achiever doesn't even matter if he
wasn't a [__] high achiever though
regardless these guys are such racist
it's a 16 year old boy and obviously in
scumbag obviously a really consistent
principle with like uh you know white
supremacist attacks or uh people who are
just like otherwise you know terrified
of black people is is the consistent way
that uh uh even in studies uh white
people end up thinking that black people
are a lot older you you uh in your mind
assume that like black teenagers are
actually full-blown adults happens to
black women happens to black men uh
black boys and black girls all the time
well regardless of age uh according to
the great minds over there it's actually
the fault lies on both sides uh clearly
as a street kid uh you certainly should
have known better so it's a street kid
yeah that's that's actually the probably
the most racist way I've heard someone
uh refer to a black person in a while
there it is Steven Crowder ladies and
gentlemen and Jim Brewer
it's a good thing they got rid of a Dave
for for Jim
is stronger yeah I mean I I would never
imagine I would say this but I preferred
the leprechaun
yeah
um
he's claiming the 84 year old is
claiming that he like opened the outside
screen door
um but uh the authorities don't believe
that the prosecutor said Ralph did not
cross the threshold into the home
um at all and for the record even if he
had like it's insane you can't just like
if someone has a uh two doors yeah and
there's like a screen door and you open
it to see inside like hey you know I'm
here to pick up my brother you don't
[__] have the right to shoot them
okay the idea that you do is is
psychotic American American [__]
brain rot it says according to miser um
Missouri law a person may generally use
physical Force if the individual
reasonably believes such force to be
necessary to defend himself or herself
or third person from what he or she
reasonably believes to be the use or
eminent use of unlawful Force by such a
person so yeah I think it's reasonable
to assume that he was afraid we have a
lack of accountability for cops
uh and and they utilize this all the
time that's why they get away with
killing people
and then that's not enough not only have
we armed every American and [__]
terrified them through our media
that people are constantly out to get
them we've also given them the same
legal authority to be able to kill
people both in your house and even
outside of your house because stand your
ground is basically a continuation of
the castle doctrine principles dude
Halloween must be crazy in Missouri
yeah it's taking shots yo everybody's
just shooting at each other I'm I in one
way I guess like the weird uh in in a
weird way uh my my brain is so broken
about this but uh the the one aspect of
this that I have seen is that the media
loves crafting narratives they love
actually uh hyper focusing on things
like after the Ohio train derailment and
uh you know Tick Tock and everyone else
like constantly pressuring the media to
cover it
train derailments are not an anomaly
they have it all the time the media
started covering all of the toxic
hazardous spills and the derailments
that were occurring Non-Stop
and now they're actually covering
stories of like people randomly being
shot because they pulled up too uh
someone's driveway in Upstate New York
where that 20 year old girl was killed
or in Dallas Texas where that
cheerleader was shot and is currently
recovering in a hospital for getting
into the wrong car right um which is
this kind of ugly in contrast with this
claim that
I don't understand why people uh don't
believe is that more guns equals more
safe mass shootings are horrifying and
and they're they're abhorrent they
should not exist but mass shootings are
not the norm the real gun violence the
the iceberg the rest of the iceberg is
actually this kind of accidental
shootings but what's even worse than
that is obviously suicides by gun uh
using a gun when you're uh committing
suicide uh or or accidental deaths
because like an accidental misfire that
happened that's the kind of that is
where the bulk of the [__] gun
violence uh numbers come from and I'm
glad that the media is covering it a
little bit more now
uh I'm glad that the media is focusing
on this a little bit more now because
this is there's a real way that uh you
know a lot of Americans die for no
[__] particular reason yep well yeah
of course like if this dude didn't have
a gun then you know oh if a lot of these
[__] morons didn't have guns these
murders wouldn't be happening but
according to somehow half of the country
uh more guns equals more safe which is
almost like a double think in a way they
they've they've convinced themselves
somehow that something is like on face
value wrong
uh that that's right and somehow I I
really don't know how these people walk
around and just uh
uh another [__] up part of the story
Ralph gets shot he's crawling away okay
uh Ralph said as he was running he heard
Mr Lester say don't come around here
okay that's number one
uh he he is like seeking help he seeks
help in the first house no answer second
help no uh second house no answer third
house he goes to the person uh before
they come outside literally tells them
to to keep their hands in the air like
that'd be awesome if he got shot again
from the third party the makeup the
makeup of the neighborhood to you know I
hope this is not surprising anyone he's
all white except for one black family
that recently moved in which was notable
enough for uh people in the neighborhood
to recognize bro what year is this
that's crazy what do you mean there's
Sundown towns all over this goddamn
country a lot of places are Sundown
towns that don't that that don't even
realize that there's unend times because
there's no black people there ever so
they don't even ever see it they don't
even recognize it
all right well there it is I'm glad he's
alive I hope he's okay I don't know how
people get shot in the head and survive
but yeah hopefully it's just such luck
of the draw like you know you hear
stories about people that like
they get shot in the head and the
bullet's still in their brain they can't
remove it and then they just like go on
and live the rest of their life like
they're like it hits the right part or
not it's just luck on the draw I guess
well that's about all I've got
mm-hmm
well you wanna wait we'd have oh we
didn't talk about that the alley thing
yeah like one of the main stories we got
to slam through this yeah
um
let me just pull up the most uh
pertinent part here so Milo as we said
who was canceled for being a pedo uh
he's a born-again Christian now straight
straight as an arrow thank God uh he was
converted into being straight here he's
revealing text messages
from Ally you don't even
so this is uh
let's see you don't even send me videos
and so this is a video of him talking
with a then
um 15 year old right this was a young
conservative kid who wanted to meet Milo
I believe
and Danny or Ali being a gatekeeper a
friend associate of Milo
uh said Aus this 15 year old I'll hook
you up but you gotta send me dick pics
and jerk off videos 15 year old
uh I'm so shocked he's now 21 years old
and I guess he's sharing these messages
with Milo and the life he's still the
freak by the way make no mistake like he
is uh he is absolutely well they're all
free but the but the one the the one who
was like victim of grooming is like
still very much if I'm not mistaken a
Nazi was outed as a Nazi when he was
like working for the uh the Colorado
branch of like uh you know uh Donald
Trump's campaign
um you know this is the this is the
funny part about this like otherwise
dark but totally expected story is that
these guys are like Duck we got into
this For the Love of the Game like we we
want to make sure that we we get the
pedophiles out of our Nazi movement you
know what I mean like they're like no
we're like actually Nazis we just don't
want the pedophile stuff like what the
[__] are you they've all been secretly
sending dick and masturbation videos to
each other he's like I know this dude
Ali's a pedo by the way but let's not
say anything about him you don't send me
videos anymore Ali said no good Jackoff
material don't even want to be by my my
side piece but I understand wonder if
you need wonder if you need to come hang
out for a week in Texas an internship
when are you coming to Texas
uh two then 15 year old
uh there's more Yeah so basically just
demonstrating on top of like the sex
stuff was like using connections like oh
this is how you'll you'll come up in the
conservative sphere actually blows my
mind that like dude the the alt right
America First is a lot they're running
it a lot like Harvey Weinstein did uh
dude but I don't I don't really okay
there's a couple things here again that
is kind of hilarious in a dark way but
it's like you're sending dick pigs to to
Ali Alexander formerly known as Ellie
Akbar
um specifically so that you can what
hang out with [__] Dan bongino at
CPAC okay Milo it's like the whack is so
[__] lame like your your aspirations
should be higher holy [__] like your
goal is to be next to uh you know the
mccloskeys or or Lauren bobert like
that's your goal in this circumstance
that's like that's the peak of your
[__] career is so that you can be
like uh like a professional racist for
for one one of these uh Republican
blowhards
insane
um
yes so Ali Alexander is this guy I'll
just show you for people who missed the
beginning he is a uh stop the Steal
or alt-right Freakazoid Protege of Roger
Stone by the way yeah uh he's friends
also was a sex past too I mean Roger
Stone
I thought there was more DMS than this
but so Nick Fuentes now everybody's
saying his fans are turning I'm saying
yo why didn't you
stop this earlier you go on and on about
pedophiles and sex Predators all show
long that you had one working with you
that you knew about so here his his
defense of that Milo has always hated
Ali and he talks about everybody in this
way he said that Kanye was gay he says
that Jesse Lee Peterson's gay he says
the caniston's husband is gay he says
that everybody's gay I think there's a
lot of people I mean if you look at his
telegram this is the case uh it's all
over there and I know that Ali was
bisexual I know that that's the case and
I know he's flirty
um
like he flirted with me when I was you
know 19 or 20. and uh maybe a little
younger and he had flirted with other
people okay so Nick says listen he
accuses everyone of being gay but then
so
um Milo dropped the DMS this is what he
sent him in January 2022. I want to flag
something reality I I liked it once
again the problem here is that they're
gay not that they're pedophiles I want
to point this out really quickly right
those who you know missing the mark they
are literally like the [__] Catholic
Church in the sense that they're like
well you know our priest might have done
some grooming maybe they did some
pedophilia but they're certainly not gay
please don't say that they're gay like
that's the that's the main point of
convention here oh my god when did God
ever say not don't [__] kids
you know what in the Bible you know what
I don't know if that's in the Bible
we're gonna ask chat gbt it'll tell me
immediately
lies a lot no no never not to me and
it's also not to me got gbts by the
devil brother
does the Bible have passages that uh
against
sexual acts with minors
the Bible does not
and then it it stopped it because it
said this is it says does not the Bible
does not that's all I got and then
they're like er I can't do this I'm just
like Googling around too and I do there
is no direct mention of pedophilia in
the Bible numerous biblical principles
that definitely apply to the sin
yeah I mean
I mean there's a lot that's not in the
Bible that people have just interpreted
differently anyways right doesn't really
[__] matter everybody picks and
chooses we all know that everyone's a
fake Christian
okay I'm trying to be less specific and
see if this works
uh the Bible does not specify any
particular age requirement for a person
to be married that awesome
speaks in general terms of marriage
between for those who are quote grown up
okay I mean that's that's sin like again
it just says the Bible does not
specifically and then they cut it
they're like nope they're like nope
we're not getting involved in this one
and this content may violate our content
policy so there it is gay bad
pedophilia
kind of dope amazing Jesus Christ I mean
they I mean we know that already because
the very same people that are like gay
people are groomers gay people are
groomers gay people are pedophiles are
the same people who literally want to uh
you know abolish age and consent laws or
want to legalize child uh Brides child
marriages a lot of these people
including Matt Walsh have defended child
marriages uh Ben Shapiro's defended
child marriages Tucker Carlson has
defended child marriages like these guys
only care about uh what they perceive as
like pedophilia which is just like a
queer person existing that's the only
bad thing a bad show up when it's like
good wholesome Christian white boys uh
doing this thing it's it's it's fine God
wanted that as God intended
so Nick says hey I couldn't know uh he
was saying that everyone's case so Milo
dropped these DMS from the beginning of
last year he said I wanted to flag
something real Ali Alexander in case
this hasn't reached you I have three
boys who are going on the record saying
Ali groomed and or molested them so
again he's even going like look he's a
pedo yeah they they were molested or
groomed uh under that promise of career
opportunity what did Nick say to that
let's it's an Open Secret and gay
right-wing circles and all will be
toppling out soon my instincts tells me
the Christianity stuff is insincere and
desperate Nick says oh boy okay thanks
for the heads up that's the that's gonna
be not good for me but if he's raping
kids he shouldn't be in politics
shouldn't be in polished I mean he
should maybe be in jail yeah just not
politics
uh so we're a way to word that Milo said
typical grooming stuff will come out
this year whether I release it or not
there's a circle of alley casualties who
are in touch with one another and
actively seeking to get their stories
out
climbing into bed was 16 17 year olds
Etc and Nick just said Bruh Bruh moment
bruh so he knew about this like the
whole time
crazy huh well at least since the
beginning of last year which you know is
a long time ago yeah before all the
Kanye stuff went down and everything
because this Ali Alexander guy correct
me if I'm wrong Hassan but he was part
of the crew that was advising uh Kanye
during his whole uh Nazi Arc that he had
last year I don't remember if I know
Milo and Nick were involved and I'm
pretty sure Ali was like went to
Mar-A-Lago with them and all that stuff
when they did dinner with Trump uh
Alexander Ollie Alexander was also a
part of the team alongside Milo
andopoulos and like then
um I think they pushed out Milo which is
why uh like Nick and Nick and Ally
stayed and
yeah
here's the crew Alex Jones who cannot
stop talking about demon pedophiles is
here pictured with one that apparently
this dude even knew about uh at the
beginning of last year so here's a pedo
and a pedo protector and here is the guy
who tells you the pedophiles are
everywhere dude every other week there's
like a high level GOP official that is
outed as like having terabytes of
[__] child porn or like literally sex
trafficking miners to have sex with them
or whatever and it doesn't [__]
matter the movement doesn't even the
movement doesn't even Flinch doesn't
scroll down it doesn't slow down
obviously I've said this time and time
again but like every accusation is a
confession by these [__] freaks okay
every single one uh they are the actual
pedophiles and what do you do when
you're a real pedophile you just say
other people are pedophiles because
everybody understands the pedophilia is
[__] bad is the most abhorrent thing
you can [__] do so you just keep
saying no no it's not me it's all those
other people just like that [__] Q
Anon guy who uh has has talked a big
game about like you know killing
pedophiles and whatever literally
convicted uh convicted pedophile who
like served a prison sentence for it and
he's like you know leading the movement
on the channel five yeah exactly these
guys all these guys have all done this
[__] yes so this is really interesting
Milo's been trying to warn uh folks
about him I guess for a while here's
Milo on Alex Jones Show so Alex actually
also is familiar with this uh accusation
quite
there are others so here he is on info
homosexual still scrambling for
attention scrambling for money and I
look at them and I see where I was and I
am a greatly uh enhanced I think human
being uh compared to I I watched this
sort of like Ali Alexander's and you
know whatever try to keep their
homosexuality Under Wraps but not very
successfully and I and I think to myself
if I could only get you know half an
hour in the room with these guys and and
try to explain to them try to show them
the sort of peace and calm and and by
the way enormously heightened
Effectiveness um that you get from
drawing closer to your spiritual life
um you know it I I just wish I could get
them all in the room because there are
some of them are well I'll be clear I
know Ollie I didn't know any of that I
know Alex
he just said his name yeah yeah yeah oh
and I have a great I have a great detail
for you when you're done with this we're
fighting the good fight brother you want
to know one thing like
it's kind of like um
when your character is is such in the in
the dumps that like you kind of get to a
point where like you can't be further
character assassinated like you can't
defame someone who's in the muck you
know
um that's the that's kind of the thing
with these guys like they're all such
disgusting scumbags with audiences full
of also disgusting scumbags because they
are marginal
and and the people that gravitate
towards that kind of commentary are like
actual [__] freaks a lot of them
though yeah that like this kind of stuff
doesn't really move the needle for them
like they don't really give a [__] they
kind of like it you know what I mean
right well
oh they're hypocritical about pedophilia
okay who cares is like the the attitude
that people have like when you look at
it from our end of the spectrum our end
of the political spectrum and go wow
that's [__] insane like these guys
are infighting but there's a reason why
I I rarely ever give them any Credence
or any coverage whatsoever I hope that
people watching this who are fans of
crowder or shabibo and seeing clips of
maybe Fuentes or Milo that they like
that they'll see this and be like um oh
where's the Crowder video on this
where's the Ben Shapiro video on this uh
this conspiracy
you know these these people are cowards
probably won't be seeing it anytime you
will not be seeing and yeah uh this is
what I wanted to point out is that um
you were saying the photo of all them
together that Nick Fuentes was uh
covering up for it Alex Jones in a way
was as well because that clip that we
just watched
um on Infowars they edited out that
section yeah
yeah this this account had it archived
that's what we just watched but uh they
say if you go they were doing a massive
cover-up yep there you go probably talk
about that Alex uh you talk about
pedophiles enough man you were just
photographed with one and now you're
covering up for him here um I call him I
call him clammy Davis Jr because he
because he's quite fond of 19 year olds
but um no he's
um come on don't listen I don't know
anything about that actually he was fond
of 16 year olds too I forgot about it
all right okay Ollie's a nice guy but
but seriously Alex is like hey hey hey
hey hey he's like Hillary Clinton's a
demonic pedophile demon hey hey hey hey
I got through in crazy accusations
around here so there you go they're all
scumbags they're all liars they're total
giant there it is you know what I mean
there it is that's all we have to say
today right Hassan yeah
I uh
it's one of those things like I said
where I feel like I need a [__]
hazmat suit to like look at any of this
[__] like I feel like it gives me
psychic damage every time I see yeah
people live lives like this
um the worst part about it we're running
out of time Fox News uh wait wait did we
talk about the settlement
thank you sorry go ahead uh his son well
all I was going to say is like it's even
sadder that there are people that follow
these guys uh who go deeper and darker
into the precipes of Hell into the
depths of hell
um for those who you know are hate
watching maybe right now we're looking
for a clippable moment or whatever uh
Salvation is possible you can change
your attitude you can change your mind
but it all starts with uh you know
moving away or why are you Tweeting
during our show
um
well now that my check mark is gone uh
immediately my own stands are changing
their profile picture to mine uh names
that are close to mine and they're
saying you know
they're I'm creating [__] like I'm gay
come on dude you know what I mean
can't you can't you do the I'm gay stuff
like in 10 minutes I didn't tweet that
Ethan
yeah well I had to defend myself
you gross I had to defend myself from
the gay alligator yeah yeah ew never all
right thank you guys it's a joke for
everyone I mean I am not gay but you
know we're joking when we say you gross
before people freak the [__] out over
yeah people all right let's let's take
us out
um
thank you guys we love ya thanks for
being here tomorrow's episode is gonna
be awesome we're gonna play Guess Who's
high like this one apparently this one
that turned out to be not that good oh
what the [__] I love my co-host's
tweeting the whole time I mean
all right the song's almost over
tomorrow we're doing that and
and uh the Powerpoints on how to spend
the 620 000. thank you
[Music]